[Music]
should police officers emergency
responders be mandated to get vaccines
and if not should they be
stay at home or let go yes and yes those
who just try to make this a political
issue freedom
i have the freedom to kill you
with my covey no i mean come on freedom
president biden demanding first
responders who fail to comply with
vaccine mandates lose their jobs and
mocking people using freedom as a
defense for not choosing to get the
vaccine this is new york city announces
a vaccine mandate for first responders
and city workers and here now to react
is new york congresswoman elise stefanik
good morning to you congresswoman
great to be with you ainsley so good to
see you so what's your reaction when you
hear him say that
my reaction is this is absolutely absurd
and sadly it's very typical of joe biden
and the biden administration to attack
americans everyday freedoms
first of all they're turning their backs
on law enforcement officers and first
responders who put their lives and their
health on the line every single day
particularly during the coveted pandemic
we've also seen in new york state the
consequence of these unconstitutional
mandates with governor hochul's mandate
requiring health care officials having
that mandate regarding vaccines we've
seen walkouts and this is while our
health care our hospitals our community
health centers have already faced
staffing shortages and even in my
district we have a rural hospital that
is no longer able to deliver children
deliver babies because of these mandates
so it's unconstitutional it is an attack
on everyday freedoms and it's something
that house republicans are fighting back
against and i give credit to republican
governors across the country who are
also challenging these unconstitutional
uh announcements from the administration
yeah and there's certain circumstances i
mean you mentioned hospitals that can't
deliver babies because they don't have
the workers the espn sideline reporter
who wanted to get pregnant her doctor
said not to get the shot so that she
could have a better chance of getting
pregnant because
she was worried about that and you know
for me at least time is of the essence
when i wanted to have a baby and i
wanted a baby so badly so that in circle
certain circumstances don't you think
there should be an exemption
absolutely there should be religious
exemptions and we want to encourage
every american to have those important
conversations with your doctor
we are promoting vaccines we have
invested in vaccines but every person
situation is different in many cases
people contracted covet and have that
natural immunity
so there needs to be flexibility these
mandates are unconstitutional and it's
an attack on our very freedoms in this
country and to have the president of the
united states mock freedom frankly
that's un-american what about new york
city things are about to change here
after bill de blasio said there's a
mandate
well it's just another example of new
york city spiraling out of control with
the failed leadership from mayor de
blasio particularly after two years when
we've seen skyrocketing crime numbers in
new york city the fact that he is
instituting this mandate for law
enforcement officers for first
responders for city workers it's going
to have a hugely negative impact both on
the way of life in new york city but
also on the safety and security in new
york city so new yorkers have to stand
up and demand better leadership
from their mayors from their governors
and from the president of the united
states they were our heroes 18 months
ago and now they're possibly losing
their jobs because they're not going to
get vaccinated i do want to mention that
you had a baby baby sam and this is your
first television interview since having
him there he is beautiful pictures how's
it going
it is going wonderful sam is just a joy
i as i have said to you before ainsley
it's like life before sam and after sam
and life is so much better after sam he
is smiling he is eight weeks today today
is his eight week birthday so happy
birthday baby sam from mommy is he
sleeping through the night yet probably
not right
not quite yet but he had a great night
last night he slept from 8 to 2 a.m but
i'm so excited to see him all the time i
sprang out a bag at 2 a.m well i did
have a doctor tell me if they sleep six
hours that that is the same thing as
sleep they call that sleeping through
the night so you got your first night
last night
absolutely it's so fun isn't it what's
the best part
the best part is just the amount of love
your heart grows by you know infinite
sizes and every day i love him more and
more and it also is amazing to see how
quickly they learn and absorb things
he
can recognize my voice now
my they had turned on the tv when i had
a press conference with my house
republican colleagues and he turned his
head and recognized my voice so it's
just so so special and i'm so proud to
be his mom well you were teaching him
about the country the importance of
hard work
because you're a congresswoman i don't
know how you're balancing all of this
but god bless you and i know sam's going
to have a wonderful life he's going to
learn so much from you
thank you so much you're welcome thank
you congresswoman